il est toujours à ma mère quand elle me
disait j'espère que tu vas avoir le bac
cette année tu dis
tu crois quand je vais avoir 30 ans
trois que les gens vont me demander à
quel âge j'ai le bac parce qu'on a
[__] j'ai dit question
là je travaillerai demain je vous jure
que c'est vrai
mais non mais après
mais je vous dis la vérité en vrai c'est
vrai que les mecs stressez pas on va la
voir ce bac si vous l'avez à 30 ans je
m'en fous non mais sans rigoler moi j'ai
eu le bac à 27 ans
sur ma vie frère moi vous savez que moi
j'ai toujours fait je fais tout le temps
d'ailleurs ce cauchemar de devoir
repasser le malin ça me honte la nuit je
vous jure que des fois je me réveille
parce que vous avez éventuellement
fraudé à l'époque
tu vas sortir définitivement non mais
pourquoi j'aime pas j'aime pas j'aime
pas la montagne
par d'autres personnes pour d'autres
personnes est-ce que vous avez
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi cette histoire c'est horrible
les chéris non non non je voulais que je
vous dis la vérité
de ma mère c'est vrai tu peux y revenir
parce que quand elle part en fait elle
part toutes les missions
c'est pas comme les autres qui viennent
ils reviennent elle elle parle elle est
partie je regardais ce qui se passe
derrière c'est hyper drôle ah non
les chéris je vous dis la vérité non non
franchement j'étais comme ça et donc
j'avais deux copains qui se
ressemblaient et j'avais un copain qui
était nul et un nez de copain qui était
très nul
et le train nul a demandé aux nul
d'aller passer le bac à sa place
il
a eu 145
[Rires]
le bac le bac c'est non mais non
personne il se ressemblait de ouf puis
c'est fragile ils ont vu que c'était des
chèvres de toute façon ils auraient
grillé s'ils avaient eu 18 de moyenne à
non mais c'est des pipes les gars
arrêtez donnez-leur et puis c'est tout
terminé non le bac le bac c'est
incroyable moi je me rappelle quand j'ai
passé le bac
attendez c'est le temps d'inventer là
non pas du tout c'était incroyable je me
rappelle c'est incroyable quoi les gens
se battaient
les gens se battaient pour être à côté
de moi
vous êtes bien les gens se battaient non
moi je me rappelle au bac parce que les
gens sont au bac sur la tête de ma mère
moi il m'arrive un truc de ouf c'est
qu'il y a des surveillants
et le surveillant je le connaissais
d'ailleurs je vous jure qu'il vient
parfois à la sécu ici sur la vie de ma
mère que c'est vrai c'est pas une vanne
et je le connaissais et donc je vais le
voir discrètement je dis frérot je vais
vérifier si les autres ont les bonnes
réponses
juste quand je parle à quelqu'un pour
vérifier qu'il a la bonne réponse je
sais que c'est vrai je te vois que tout
le bac
[Rires]
c'est juste pour vérifier j'ai un petit
doute
[Rires]
et tout le bac tout le bac j'avais les
feuilles de tout le monde
tu avais les feuilles de monde et moi un
jour je me suis fait envoyer de l'école
avant le je me suis fait envoyer du
lycée avant de passer le bac
le lycée c'est désolidarisé
[Musique]
c'est pas une balle ils ont appelé ma
mère genre en mars où est-ce que vous
pouvez venir ma mère elle est venue
voilà nous on veut pas qu'il passe le
bac sous notre bannière
donc ils ont pas voulu que je les
représente
j'allais au lycée en fait et au lycée
déjà j'avais je vous jure que c'est vrai
c'est pas une Barka je venais j'avais un
mec en fait j'avais fait un petit peu
j'avais fait un petit peu d'oseille déjà
en terminale
j'avais fait un petit peu d'oseille je
vous jure que c'est vrai la vanne c'est
l'histoire est vrai j'avais fait de
l'oseille parce que je vend des débats
et des trucs tu vois pas et j'arrive
j'arrive
à l'école on relance avec un chauffeur
non la tête de ma mère mais vous êtes
fous quoi
mais ma mère bien sûr mais sur la tête
de ma mère c'est vrai et pourquoi on
faisait ça mais parce que j'arrivais et
je ramené tout le monde après je
ramenais des gens je vais aller passer
devant l'école j'étais en russe comme ça
devant l'école j'arrive à l'école quand
même j'avais même pas de sac sur la tête
comment vous avez trouvé un chauffeur
enfin
de ce que vous voulez oncle d'un copain
à moi c'est drôle franchement je lui ai
je dis un copain qui oui je veux arriver
tous les jours on rentre à l'école et
tous les midis je t'ai [__] dans la
Rolls et je mangeais dans la Rolls mais
non il y avait une tablette il y avait
une tablette bien manger
avec moi je l'ai essayé dans la roche
sur la tête de ma mère que c'est vrai
mais dis pas vrai histoire est vraie
histoire sur la tête de ma mère c'est
pas possible comme quoi c'est pas
l'argent qui vous a rendu ou pas
né comme ça je vous jure que c'est vrai
les les profs vous voyez arriver en rôle
ma mère ma mère je savais pas elle
essaie pas que j'avais de l'oseille moi
et ben oui elle me voyait rentrer à la
maison mais on rentre quand même
rien dit votre père
je te jure que c'est vrai on veut une
confirmation de notre maman
elle va écrire là
incroyable mais cette histoire était
folle voilà des images ou pas en fait
parce que j'avais fait fortune j'avais
fait fortune déjà
dans le business
les faux bulletins les trucs comme ça
je vendais de la pub pour les golfs les
Golf les golfeurs
spécialisée pour les golfeurs ok donc
j'appuie tous les golfs et je disais
voilà est-ce que je peux vous faire de
la pub sur les terrains de golf
et j'avais fait j'avais pris beaucoup
d'oseille et ouais les gars
ou dans les magazines
de la pub voilà comme ça
mais sur ma vie mais avant le bac vous
aviez déjà autant de Moulins mes frères
avant d'avoir 18 ans non mais je te jure
après j'ai plongé
et bien sûr mais écoute-moi bien à
l'école frère mais je te jure que c'est
vrai mais c'était dans la courte moi je
suis allé même pas je montais même pas à
l'école j'étais dans la cour [__]
toute la journée j'étais dans la cour
commence je viens là viens viens viens
on va faire un petit tour viens on va
chez le visagiste
à côté j'ai qu'est-ce que tu peux me
faire là je te jure pendant la récré
j'allais me faire un truc je revenais je
j'arrive en cours genre une demi-heure
en retard j'avais la peau quand même et
j'étais faire une
[Musique]
et donc moi je sors de l'école je fais
le beau gosse j'ai la Rolls devant frère
je vois ma daronne de loin avec les
bulletins la main je vois tes papiers
iers du chauffeur attend 2 minutes on a
des il y a des récalcitrant
2 minutes mais le moteur
ouais et là ma mère me trémond les
bulletins et là je regarde tu vois bien
mon nom je vois bien mes vrais notes
je comprends pas c'est ce qu'on veut et
je vais tenir maman ça se passera pas
comme ça
je vais aller voir tout de suite le
conseiller l'éducation et je peux te
dire que ça va chier dans cette salle de
merde toi papa
que ça à [__] non mais c'est vrai et
là elle a dû vous défoncer
je joue de la maison
je suis parti de la maison
moi et ton père on veut plus de moi
c'est parti
le visage pur et le verbe
avec votre tombe à lui je suis je quitte
la maison
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
est vraie je te jure que c'est vrai
l'année d'avant ma mère était très
énervée parce que j'avais je travaillais
mal en premier et donc j'ai dû changer
le lycée ma mère m'avait donné 200
balles elle m'a dit écoute-moi bien je
peux te voir de toutes les vacances je
vais te donner 200 balles
et je vais mes affaires et je suis parti
sur je suis parti à Cannes j'ai pris un
train à m'a dit je te paye le train et
de son balle et nous on va partir aux
États-Unis je peux entendre parler de
toi je prends les 200 balles qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait j'avais dit parce que moi
en première j'avais déjà 25 ans
donc qu'est-ce que j'ai fait j'ai dit
voilà j'ai essayé 200 balles c'est très
simple où je rentre à Paris
ou bien je passe des bonnes vacances
sur la tête de ma mère que c'est vrai je
vous jure que l'histoire est vrai vous
pouvez demander à ma mère vous pouvez
demander à mes potes je suis allé au
casino arrête je suis à la machine à
sous je vous jure que c'est vrai la
machine de poker troisième coup je fais
carré de roi je gagne 20 fois ma mise oh
là là je gagne genre 4000 boules
écoute-moi bien j'étais le roi de Cannes
frère tout le monde écoute-moi bien mais
j'ai arrêté des connes qu'est-ce que tu
fais toi allez viens manger avec nous
je vous jure que c'est vrai je suis
revenu de 4 et l'histoire est vraie je
vous dire que c'est vrai je suis revenu
avec 10000 boules
de Cannes tous les soirs j'étais avec
des voitures les mecs on va prendre
notre petit billet euh j'arrivais Bam
Bam Bam je te jure que c'est vrai et un
moment j'étais dans ce que moi j'avais
nulle part à Cannes et donc en fait je
m'étais fait copain avec des des
prostituées je vous jure que c'est vrai
que tu avais pas les téléphones
portables et donc moi toute la journée
mon QG il y avait un bar qui s'appelait
le cancare et toute l'année au camp en
bas avec les prostituées
et donc ça allait de la place au camp en
bar le soir je passais ouais ça va les
filles
2 minutes
après elle elle voit que je suis dans un
hôtel à Cannes de ouf mon frère parce
qu'elle appelle des copains des trucs
ben on l'a vu tout ça finalement elle se
rend compte que je suis dans un hôtel
tranquille comme ça je suis tranquille
mon frère
elle veut m'appeler laisse un number où
je dois l'appeler là je vais au camp en
barre
j'appelle ma mère
qu'est-ce qui t'arrive là il parait que
tu t'inquiètes pour moi mais tout va
bien ma belle tout va bien ouais et
voilà
ils sont obligés de bac
et parce qu'on est parti de là en fait
on se retrouve
et j'ai le bac j'ai fait une fête de ouf
et je me rappelle pendant cette fête il
y a un truc qui m'a toujours le piné
et je l'ai jamais dit à personne c'est
le moment peut-être
je sais pas moi c'est ma mère le sait
je suis pas bien
entendu
avec les meufs au lycées ou pas mais non
mais c'est pas ça moi
tous les soirs
mais non mais non mais non mais non mais
j'étais dans la j'étais dans la tchatche
mais non
j'étais pas là en parlant du bac
à faire de famille
un pote à moi
et je me rappelle j'ai eu cette phrase
dramatique
qui j'ai parlé à ma cousine et je lui
dis si tu as pris
je peux pas vous le dire
[Applaudissements]
ou pas assez cher
ami en fait
tout le monde lequel est votre cousine
est-ce que j'ai fait
j'avais j'ai grave gagné de l'oseille
pendant le bac encore
j'ai privatisé une boîte toute première
frère c'était la soirée de l'année genre
qui va la soirée je suis arrivé mon
frère sur la tête de ma mère j'étais
habillé en blond de la tête
qu'est-ce que tu fais toi tu rentres toi
tu rentres pas un concurrent toi c'est
parti et là un moment j'ai dit les mecs
je vais arriver je te jure que c'est
vrai j'avais mis une musique
et là je suis arrivé
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête de ma mère
je suis arrivé quand Max avec le bac et
tous les gens dans la teuba le bac
[Applaudissements]
c'est l'histoire est vrai
la soirée du bac danois parce que comme
c'était pas gagné
une soirée comme ça les gars ça se
prépare pas le jour des résultats
je savais si je l'ai pas ah oui je fais
une fête j'ai pas le barbier non mais
c'est vrai ouais
écoute-moi bien il y avait Mad mes
parents et tout mais bien sûr les
parents ils m'ont mis sur une chaise
comme ça
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
on dirait que j'avais mais vous êtes
fous quoi histoire vrai et donc avec
votre cousine
c'est sensible
d'ailleurs est-ce que tu veux me poser
une question d'histoire comme ça
[Applaudissements]
en histoire
en histoire vous êtes super bon en
histoire allez vas-y alors c'est fou
alors
je pose une question simple pour se
mettre à côté de moi aussi vous êtes
calé sur l'époque napoléonienne
[Rires]
assez simple
quel général de l'armée napoléonienne
ayant participé victorieusement au
bataille de Grenade Malaga Alicante
[Rires]
à son nom gravé sur les 13e et 14e
colonne du pilier est de l'Arc de
Triomphe
attendez les mecs qu'est-ce qui se passe
qu'est-ce qui se passe
oh [__] merde un rap [__] ils ont
attrapé un rat merde
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
calmez-vous c'est ça va mon chéri
mais qu'est-ce que tu fais là en fait
comment ça s'est passé et je suis en
train de bouffon mais qu'est-ce que je
cherche à Gémo
mais comment ça se fait que tu t'es
retrouvé là et je viens d'emménage là
Molitor dans le 16e là c'est à son
Molitor je m'appelle Gabriel Jean-Joseph
et on m'a dit qu'à la facto les
chroniqueurs ça mangeait bien donc
cherché à Gémeaux d'accord très bien
merci en tout cas et tu peux me passer
le fromage qui est là le fromage idéal
il est là
à Molitor dans le 16e station Molitor
j'en emménagé là avec les potes et c'est
quoi le bail après
Gabriel Jean-Joseph
[Rires]
tu m'as demandé un truc oui le général
de l'armée napoléonienne qui a participé
victorieusement à plusieurs
noms est gravé
[Applaudissements]